the Frasers pixar movie and easter eggs
go together like peanut butter and jelly
fans always anticipate the studio's
freshest release to be full to bursting
with fun references and wings to pop
culture and director Lee and critters
journey into the land of the dead with
Koko is by no means an exception here
are just a few of the Easter eggs and
Koko you may have missed and it goes
without saying but spoilers ahead famous
food delivery a Pixar movie must to the
pizza planet delivery truck first
appeared in 1995 Toy Story and has
popped up in almost every single film
animation studio has rolled out since
the truck sits outside a trailer in a
bug's life drives across a bridge of
ratatouille and that can be spotted in
Koko right outside Miguel's house near
the beginning of the movie as a young
boy stares wistfully outside the Pizza
Planet truck zooms past his window the
anticipated a113 like the Pizza Planet
truck the letter number combination of
a113 has deep roots in the Pixar film
pantheon though it extends its reach
into plenty of non Pixar animated films
and television shows the four figure
code is actually a reference to room a 1
1 3 the classroom the animation industry
a-listers attended a California
Institute of the Arts and just like in
every other Pixar movie a 1 1 3 shows up
in Cocoa specifically in the Land of the
Dead
written back was on the door of the
Bureau of family grievances whether
deceased members of the Rivera family
go-to coordinator way to San Miguel back
where he belongs
Pixar pinatas sticking with the nods to
Pixar projects past koko also features a
tucked away reference to a few of its
other movies Toy Story and monsters Inc
as Miguel dashes through his villages
markets towards the central plaza and
the beginning of the movie viewers will
notice that he runs past a bundle of
pinatas in the shape of cowboy woody and
astronaut Buzz from Toy Story and the
one-eyed green skinned monster Mike
Wazowski from monster's Inc near the
back of the pinata park is a turquoise
one likely designed to look like Mike's
partner Sulley familiar figurines after
grabbing a bite to eat on his way to the
plaza
Miguel happens upon a table lined with a
LaBrie Hayes Mexican folk art sculptures
that depict fantastical creatures
painted in bright colors and bold
patterns hidden amongst these striking
sculptures are small figurines of the
clown
fish Marlin animo and the Regal blue
tang fish Dory from Finding Nemo look
carefully and you'll also see trinkets
of the rat chef Remi from ratatouille
and the whale shark destiny from finding
Dory never forgotten Nemo there's yet
another Nemo figure for viewers to find
in Coco this time when the Rivera
family's ofrenda
you'll spot the little guy join the
scene in which a bolita Lena places the
photo of mama Coco mama Imelda and
Miguel's great-great-grandfather he sits
atop a jar on the right hand side of the
screen just behind the mustachioed
skeleton in a suit and top hat
the luxo ball Pixar's famous ball
officially called the luxo ball in
reference to the studio's first ever
animated short to luxo jr. is yet
another staple of the studio's efforts
the yellow bouncy ball adorned with a
thick blue stripe and red star appears
in cocoa drawing the rehearsal sequence
featuring Frida Kahlo what's the
background carefully has Dante the dog
and Frida's monkey went after each other
in the workshop the ball can be seen on
a table in a super quick moment the
inspired performer if wardrobe choices
are any indication it's possible that
one of Pixar's oldest characters Sid
from the original Toy Story may no
longer be in the land of the living
during the talent show one performer
took the stage with a familiar looking
t-shirt sure that has different and he's
not making monsters out of toys but only
one guy in Pixar's history was dark
enough to wear that shirt despite how
sad is that Sid's somehow ended up in
the Mexican afterlife being a skeleton
DJ's got to be better than being a
garbage man a legendary voice John
Ratzenberger and that's the best known
for his long-running volunteers and his
voiceover work has become a Pixar legend
he's lent his pipes to a character in
every one of the studio's films
including ham the piggy bank in Toy
Story mark the 18-wheeler and cars and
the Yeti in Monsters Inc
welcome today Emily that's expected
Ratzenberger plays a part in cocoa but
it's so brief that it likely breezed
right by you
Ratzenberger voices of goofy skeleton
whose dentist is the one who remembers
him in the land of the living thanks to
his massive mouth of metal Pixar's
personal ofrenda last but in no way
lease is a touching tribute to a few
influential people who have sadly passed
away the cocoa team included it's very
own a friend or of sorts and the film's
credits with a series of photographs
honoring those who have had an impact on
Pixar as a whole Steve Jobs the
co-founder of Apple who was also a CEO
and shareholder of Pixar Don Rickles
famed insult comic and the voice of mr.
Potato Head in the Toy Story movies and
Joe ramped the voice actor behind
Heimlich in a bug's life and shark in
Finding Nemo director Lee Unkrich
confirmed jobs and Rickles inclusion to
Metro in an interview at the very end of
the movie we kind of do a digital
ofrenda where we gave everyone in the
company the opportunity to submit a
photograph of someone in their life who
is no longer with them but have been
supportive of them and we just filled
the screen with hundreds and hundreds of
these beautiful images we included
people in that group that we had lost
from the Pixar family people like Steve
Jobs and Don Rickles thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love tank
[Music]